foreign
Alabama it looks like we have a question
from Facebook Louise has a question as a
recovering people pleaser how do I leave
behind the person I tried to be for
others and get back to my authentic self
Dr Nicole you talk a lot about being
your authentic self and I love the way
that you talk about it because it's it's
not about just simply being the best
version the robotic version of yourself
right and I want to be clear with Luis
your authentic self is not found in the
expectation of others right we're always
people pleasing as a recovering people
pleaser myself I realize because of you
that that is a type of codependency yeah
I want to kind of build on this a bit
too and and say you know that who we are
our authentic self isn't contained in
any role that we play for someone else
at all and actually piggyback on the
last conversation that we were just
having around emotions and what you said
Ryan about kind of the you know
temporary nature of the human existence
I mean we are evolving energetic
creatures in terms of our authentic self
in terms of our emotions we are changing
more than we're stagnant and all this
idea around attachment and clinging and
while many of us might feel like we're
stuck in a feeling a role the people
please or we're stuck maybe in fear and
anxiety and we make that all of who we
are often the the time often is the case
we're living in our mind with that idea
and we're creating that then we're
filtering the world through that thought
that idea again at one time likely and
this is where I'll get into kind of the
adaptation that people-pleasing can be
likely playing a role might have kept us
safe likely our nervous system might be
dysregulated caught in a fear-based
response because like me we didn't have
that tuned caregiver to bring us back
into safety we come to know ourselves as
this very solid and you know kind of
unchanging thing but a lot of that is
because of our subconscious mind the
habits the patterns that we're stuck as
our authentic self is really a changing
energetic you know entity for lack
really of a better word so anytime we're
inhabiting a role and that's all we can
experience ourselves as in relationships
whether it's the people pleaser or the
helper again I would make a case that
that's not necessarily a reflection of
who we are who we are is the being
behind the person who maybe does
sometimes make the choice to be helpful
to be available to please another but
for a lot of us that's the only way we
know ourselves to be and oftentimes in
childhood scanning the environment
becoming hyper Vigilant anticipating the
needs of someone else and that very
people-pleasing mode might have been the
only way that we created safety from
maybe an unpredictable parent or an
unavailable parent who we had to get the
little bit that was available to us when
they were here so we had to be really
attuned to them and making sure that
they were calm and grounded and happy
enough that they could connect with us a
little bit way that they could and then
before we know it that becomes our
embodied way of being we're the people
pleaser who going back to the idea of
resentment before long were so depleted
so in service of other people our needs
have gone unmet for so long of course
I'm speaking from my own personal
journey and we're so mad at the world
around us we're so desperate to find the
person who we don't have to people
please yet again we back ourselves in
the corner because when it comes down to
it we don't know any other way to be man
so I need to hear this again and I think
Luis seems to hear this again but um
what did you say uh your identity is not
formed by what you do for others by the
role you play for others by the role you
play for others tweet that podcast on
that feels to me like we all if we see a
rainbow what do we see we see all the
colors I've never seen just a red
rainbow
right not yet
and pretty scary and yet when we see
someone and we see them just as one role
oh you're just a mother oh you're just
an entrepreneur oh you are just a sister
oh you're just a daughter whatever it is
that one role that is a support role and
it can be really useful to support
others but when our entire identity gets
wrapped up in that one role that one
color of the rainbow we cease to see the
whole person for who they are
Dr Nicole said something she said uh
we're continually evolving beings and
when I think about Evolution I think
about how there's no Evolution without
some form of Extinction right in order
to grow into our authentic self or in
order to do the things that make us come
alive we have to be willing to die to
those aspects of ourselves and those
habits and those roles and so on that
don't serve us that are not capable of
moving forward with who life is causing
us to become and when I think about this
dying aspect I think it's important to
think about it as a process not a
one-time event so it's a little bit like
the horror movies you know the last
scene of every horror movie what happens
they they finally killed the monster and
the Monsters lying there dead and
everybody breathes a sigh of relief and
they all hug each other and celebrate
and then when they turn around to look
at where the body's supposed to be the
body's gone and then there's always
and you know there's going to be a
sequel right yeah but you don't respond
bonds to the existence of that sequel as
if something bad has happened you know
that's part of the game right and it's
the same way with life when we kill the
monsters the monster of the people
pleaser within us that's not a one-time
thing there's gonna be a sequel It's a
continual process and so the relapse
doesn't mean you don't care the relapse
doesn't mean you aren't serious about
change the relapse doesn't mean you
haven't grown the relapse means that you
are a human that this is a process and
that life is all about growing and
continuing to grow and not using our
moments of relapse against ourselves and
so be encouraged as you have those
moments where you feel like you're doing
really good you're recovering people
pleaser and then you have one of those
moments where you just let somebody talk
you into something that you didn't want
to do don't give up and don't say ah I'm
just the same old me that I've always
been nope you're a better you you're
getting so much better but you just had
a moment and that's life did you enjoy
this standalone patreon on highlight if
so you can listen to full episodes of
the minimalists private podcast
available exclusively on patreon visit
patreon.com the minimalists or click the
link in the description your support
keeps our podcast and YouTube Channel
100 advertisement free